foreign
is called the photo Friday home tour
this is number 12 in this photo Friday
series and this one is titled minimalist
Halloween decorations so Halloween is
less than a week away right now I'm so
spooked out right now I'm scared I have
my contacts in too I can't even see them
bring that over here Danny so if you're
watching this you can see on the screen
this is a wooden skull about no no can
we get some ghost music in the
background Alabama
all right so you can see on the screen
above my shoulder here there is this
picture of my entryway and we have these
shelves there and this is pictures taken
at night so we have the lights on
there's a bunch of just regular
different objects and then at the bottom
we have these two pumpkins
and they are two white pumpkins oh to go
with our decor and uh they're stacked on
top of a lot of people use things
which that's what we hand out instead of
candy we hand out a lot of people use
things and how books that you're
I mean not worse than the apples you
give out the ones with the razor blades
in them oh you know but you know what
that's a very good tactic to keep kids
away from next Halloween yeah that's
what we're trying it's really what it is
you just keep it away for your kids love
people
that guy gives out books don't go there
you can see the uh the photo here and
and we actually have more Halloween
decorations uh more than this but we
wanted to find a way to both adhere to
our rather simple aesthetic and we were
at the grocery store going to buy
pumpkins for Ella to carve up with us
right in little decorative gourds and I
saw these white pumpkins and I'm like oh
these would actually look great on the
Shelf so we can inject a little bit of
the the seasonality into the home it
doesn't have to be completely sterile
right but
I just imagine you looking at the white
pumpkins and how
like I could just see you getting like
almost not excited but like your OCD was
like so pleased
your OCD was like this is gonna fit
great on those shelves no I prefer not
to have them at all like it was just me
living by myself there's no way I'm
gonna have this but I have a family and
and so like with and I surprised them so
I put them I put them on the shelf and
next morning Ella was like super excited
to see them she's like we have Halloween
decorations and
um and Bex is like oh you're the best
these look great and so like
aesthetically I think it was this middle
ground that worked well for all of us
for Ella we also have the pumpkins that
she can carve out and we put on the
porch and what I recognized is that like
we have these objects to try to make the
space beautiful I don't need any of them
they're all non-essentials every object
you see in this picture in fact is a
non-essential but they add some sort of
value to our lives some aesthetic Beauty
to our space which is important to us us
so every Friday we send out a photo on
patreon for anyone who watches the video
version of the minimalist podcast where
we just go through these little home
tour things and I thought this was this
was nice for this episode since
Halloween is right around the corner and
Ella I think is going to be a princess
ninja this year yeah yeah oh heck yeah
that's awesome a few weeks ago we I
might be a princess ninja this year it's
pretty awesome we're gonna duke it out
he's got the best princess ninja costume
uh you've always been a princess ninja
in my book right now
you always know the right things to say
to me and so what we have in our space
here on these shelves is you know some
things that add value to our lives
they're decorative in one sense so they
are aesthetic they're pieces of Art and
we have collected them over a period of
time and one thing that we do to keep
the space fresh is move them around from
time to time so it's not the same thing
over and over and so this shelf might
have artwork from a completely different
shelf than that somewhere else in the
house or we just move a few things
around and every quarter or so actually
every quarter is when I do it you know
it's on my calendar but every quarter
I'll move some things around to keep the
space Anew and so it's the same space
but it always feels fresh and that's
never stale it's never the same thing
and having these small little Halloween
decorations that will go bad shortly
after Halloween it's great for the
season but then I'm forced to Let It Go
because if I cling to it it rots and
what a metaphor for the consumer
purchases most of the things we're
holding on to have been rotten you can
pickle them
oh sorry please me first uh they look
really good man I I'm projecting my own
my OCD is like oh man that's nice it
matches the shelves all right guys
minimalist movie idea The Grinch Who
permitted Halloween starring Josh
he comes in with his white pumpkin gets
rid of the orange one he's like that
children this is more aesthetically
pleasing this is the climax in the movie
I'm not investing in that
you're always crapping on my dreams to
be the Grinch Ryan
at least twice as big as his because
like all of this lack of Aesthetics
maybe that could be the Scrooge of
Halloween instead
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free